die grünen haben zum grundsatz konvent
eingeladen und alle aus deutschen männer
die sich für die grünen interessieren
sind gekommen
ja ich bin da
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wer sind sie was machen sie beruflich
weiter ich bin robert und seit einem
jahr hauptberuflich mit den grünen
unterwegs
[Musik]
glückwunsch momentan der beliebteste
politiker deutschland ist ist das such
such oder pflegen also flur oder segen
das ist schall und rauch und geht vorbei
natürlich bekam aber auch die statistik
besagt dass ja überwiegend junge frauen
wählen die grünen
danke ich wähle sie ja ich bin ja
überwiegend alte männer wählen sie nicht
sterben aus dass ich das charmante große
fähre vom westen über gemacht obama ist
nach gelände dass man den rohstoff mehr
oder weniger einfach ausverkauft hat
daher kommt wie frühstück statt und das
kann man nicht von heute auf morgen
ändern können wir nicht etwas tun gegen
den frust im ausstellen dass wir das
hier zum beispiel dass ihr grün den den
den menschen im osten was zurück gibt es
muss ja nicht immer programme seien
manchmal reichen ja auch einfach
sachwerte welche zb die kriegen schon
unseren so lieb
[Musik]
was auch ein glas sekt aus nacht wurde
das verstehe ich respekt überhaupt
kontakt wer sind sie sie sind ja quasi
die attraktivste doppelspitze in der
partei landschaft ist es nicht
eigentlich deprimierend dass es dann
doch nach so vielen jahren wieder nur um
äußerlichkeiten geht ja dass robert war
mein blaues kleid spricht das hat mich
auch verbunden hat ja hat er das gemacht
wir haben sie nicht zugehört nein
natürlich bei einem urologen hören ja
auch das zdf in sich zu ja aber gerade
da wurde ich abgelenkt habe ich nicht
gesagt lenkt mich nicht ab jetzt fällt
mir auf die füße
es geht ja noch sehr viel um
unglaubwürdigkeit was was macht dir
besser
ich glaub die fängt mit ihrer
rückwärtsgewandtheit das bedürfnis
zurück in den mutterleib ganz gut ein
und ich glaube dass unsere vorsitzenden
ganz gut klar gemacht dass das keine
alternative ist in dieser welt
ab einem gewissen alter zurück in den
mutterleib wird schwer schon räumlichen
das problem ist ja im osten
ich sah die natur wieder im kommen der
mensch wird zurückgedrängt also nicht
nur der ball auch du ja der luxair lu
gespeicherte her der braunbär der
braunbär selbst der wald pinguin
immerhin es gibt sie wieder ist doch
super duffy zeug viehzeug natur natur
ich meine aber was hat die natur für
mich gemacht ich muss immer irgend etwas
für die natur tun hat die natur schon
einmal irgendwas zurückgegeben
sie hat sie gebaut ein wunder der natur
das stimmt viele menschen
die ju traumzielen ziehen weg und lassen
die männer mit ihren grundbedürfnissen
rührte zurück naja also ob so viele
frauen aus dem ausland fliehen weiß ich
gar nicht so genau das ist also alle
erfasst also es gibt im osten noch eine
frau und die ist glaube ich auch und man
hat sich jetzt herausgestellt
ein erfolgreicher abend mir wurde
geholfen und auch ich konnte helfen
welcher partei das wird sich natürlich
erst am ballabend herausstellen und
damit zurück zum alten weißen mann
[Musik]